election day in australia voters turned
up to cast their vote
i think we need a little bit of
disruption here in australia in fact i
think we need a lot of disruption we
need people who can stand up and and
have opinions and thoughts not based on
parties there's been a few things
obviously in the last three years
especially during the pandemic that
there's the government just has got
wrong
after six weeks on the campaign trail
the prime minister scott morrison
returned to his sydney electorate
flanked by his wife and two daughters
the coalition leader made a last-minute
pitch to voters i'm the first prime
minister in a very long time that's been
able to go through a term and face the
people on a second time and i'm seeking
that support because i know this country
is facing some strong and difficult and
challenging times
the labour party was ahead in
pre-election polls that sentiment played
out at the ballot box with anthony
albanese ousting the coalition
government ending nine years of
conservative rule tonight the australian
people have voted for change
[Applause]
i am humbled by this victory
and i'm honored to be given the
opportunity
to serve as the 31st prime minister of
australia
the liberal national party lost safe
blue ribbon seats to a group of
high-profile female independents who
campaigned on climate change gender
equality and integrity
scott morrison took responsibility for
the party's loss thanked australians and
declared he will step down as leader of
the liberal party it is proper to
acknowledge the functioning of our
democracy
i've always believed in australians and
their judgment
and i've always been prepared to accept
their verdicts and tonight they have
delivered their verdict and i
congratulate anthony albanese in the
labor party and i wish him and his
government all the very best while
labour has won the most seats in this
election counting continues and what we
don't know is whether or not anthony
albanese has a clear majority or if
australia faces the prospect of a hung
parliament and the labor party needs to
do a deal with the minor parties and the
independents to govern
sarah clark al jazeera sydney